through frequent dive trips to a PO
island renee has befriended many of the
locals Senan is a third-generation
fisherman who has spent his entire life
on the island living off its resources
he and his son Jory make daily trips to
spear fish for the family Renee tells me
there's no better way to understand the
importance of the reefs to the people
here than to watch them at work with the
simplest homemade equipment sent on and
joori dive to depths of several meters
holding their breath for minutes at a
time it's beautiful to watch this father
and son are so in tune with the ocean
they almost look like they belong
underwater but the fish they're hunting
for are nowhere to be found
after a day in the water
Zen and Joey have invited us back for a
meal Apple Island has a small population
and there are a few resources beyond
what the sea provides there are no cars
on the island and most people eat with a
catch or grow
and Oppo Island is not unusual the
Philippines is made up of more than
7,000 islands and hundreds of thousands
of Filipinos lived just like this
sent on usually serves up what he finds
on the reefs but today it's canned fish
Josh yes please
this would be a typical amount for four
people right bit more than four maybe
even didn't more than four this actually
yummy yeah this is very today when we
were watching we saw that there wasn't
really much for you to catch there yeah
so this is not fresh fish
he's a can fish does that happen a lot
nice blue like to look 103d soon out of
a week sometimes no catch three days out
of the week night was I know what my own
their meal said he they don't care they
just don't eat has it always been like
that
oh no no no no anomalous I'm vindicated
is lots of fish used to be lots and lots
of fish um so then can they still exist
off of what it what remains this hood so
in his best-case scenario what does he
want for it today and what does he want
for tomorrow I don't media because I'm
maka maka I own something I don't want
to know the end he'll look up between
living okay come on oh come on oh he's
out fishing every day while you're in
school yes when you finish with your
studies there you're gonna stay on the
island didn't know maybe yeah so then is
he happy that his sons and daughters are
finding different opportunities and
moving off the island or is he sad that
that way of life is broken now pineapple
Nino oh he wants them back he'd rather
have them on yeah he wants them Terrace
kanava is da completo don't a movie